don't be shocked they're neither sauce
or no Sanders or any friend of Israel
remember sauce or attacked the State of
Israel repeatedly promoted the BDS
movement even caught in numerous
anti-semitism scandals and by the way
she offered she supports Sharia law even
attacked a survivor of female genital
mutilation for criticizing Islam and
Bernie making her a campaign surrogate
also a friend of the biggest most
virulent anti-semite racists in the
country and that would be Nation of
Islam leader
screwie Louis Lewis Farrakhan joining us
now with reaction we welcome her to the
Fox News Channel family that would be
former White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders welcome aboard Sarah good to
have you it's great to be with you
thanks for having me on Sean just big
picture you know the president as well
as anybody in the country you know is
thinking you know his mindset I look at
this cast of extremists and I'm like wow
I guess the only one that can beat
Donald Trump is Donald Trump which I
don't think he's gonna allow to happen
not for a minute I think Donald Trump
the reason you saw him so happy so
joyful tonight not only because the
country is doing well but because if
this is the best the Democrats have to
offer then the president has to be
elated
honestly Sean I'm not even sure why any
of these candidates are running they
seem to all have such a dislike for this
country dislike for American citizens I
don't know why they want to try to lead
them what the policies and the positions
that these individuals are pushing is
beyond hard to comprehend why anyone
would support these individuals I'm not
even sure Joe Biden knows what election
he's in and what position he's running
for he seems to be so confused all the
time I hope that this is the best that
we have coming out of the Democrat Party
because if it is we're gonna have
another great four years of President
Trump come 2020 I tend to agree and not
only that the president more than any
other politician I can think of as
actually double-dot kept his word
everyone I got a lot of criticism from
conservatives one when he was running
because I vouch for his conservative
views and I said he means it even though
he lived in a liberal state let the city
like New York and secondly people said
well the president
given up on securing the borders and no
he hasn't he switched gears he came up
with a better strategy and he knows he
has the legal justification and
constitutional justification for the
reallocation of funds from the Defense
Department and that money is now
officially his and the border wall is
being built and Nancy Pelosi is
complaining she couldn't stop them
exactly not only is the president
winning on a campaign promise after
campaign promise but he's doing it on
his own without the help of Democrats in
Congress they've spent every minute of
the president's term fighting against
him and trying to tear him apart instead
of building this country up they just
this week they finally come back to work
and the only thing that they can do is
try to figure out how to impeach the
president they are terrified of his
success because they know that the more
he continues to do well and when the
harder it is for Democrats to get
elected and that is their singular focus
it has nothing to do with helping
America it has nothing to do with
helping people across this country I'm
pretty sure they don't even like America
if you listen to what they're saying
everything they have to say is so
negative and you saw the exact opposite
of that from the president tonight and I
hope that people will continue to look
at that contrast and see that you have
somebody who loves this country loves
all of the citizens of this country
versus the Democrats who have nothing to
do but take the president attack this
president and try to tear them down
Sarah thank you
welcome to the family we're glad to have
you